the second thing is the potential harms
of consuming organ Meats organ meats are
concentrated sources of some of these
nutrients and some of them that have
upper tolerable levels that we want to
stable low so one of those is pre-formed
vitamin A which an excessive intake in
pregnancy has been linked to birth
defects so that's one of the nutrients
that all of the major health
organizations are like don't get too
much preformed vitamin A during
pregnancy so that's retinol that's the
kind that's found in animal Foods the
other source of vitamin A is carotenoids
which is found in plant foods which
there is not an upper tolerable level
for because our body excretes any excess
we can meet all of our vitamin A needs
with plant foods and if we consume a lot
of it no harm no foul we get rid of it
let's look at sort of where we currently
are and where are sort of maybe some
small changes we can start with and then
sort of build from there taking really
manageable steps for overall health and
we keep sort of harping on too yes we're
talking specifically about fertility but
so many of these things are also the
same when it comes to pregnancy when it
comes to overall optimal diet to reduce
risk of chronic disease when I'm
counseling a client I like to try to get
them away from focusing on quantitative
measures of health and really focus on
qualitative and specifically what we
want to add to the diet how can I add
more of these beneficial fats that I
know are going to be helpful for
improving my fertility chances or
improving my pregnancy like how can I
get more avocados in my diet where can I
add more nuts and seeds from this
perspective of abundance versus a
perspective of what needs to be limited
yeah
that was Whitney English and Alex
caspero from plant-based Juniors to
Pediatric dietitian nutritionists
best-selling authors and mothers who are
passionate about helping parents and
kids get more plants on their plates
their books are the predominantly
plant-based pregnancy guide and the
plant-based baby and toddler the
complete feeding guide for infants and
toddlers their messages focused on
healthy pregnancy baby LED weaning and
raising healthy kids and relies on
evidence-based nutrition for the
recommendations giving advice based on
Research not Dogma with so many
decisions that come with figuring out
how to nourish yourself and your
children Whitney and Alex help clear the
mud with evidence-based nutrition advice
to help others feel confident in their
choices plant-based Juniors also
recently launched the Learning Center
with Dr reshma Shaw as a platform for
healthcare providers and parents to
learn more about pediatric nutrition
their Flagship course pediatric
nutrition for healthcare professionals
just launched and is approved for 35
continuing education credits for doctors
dietitians nurses and other Healthcare
professionals so check that out linked
below if you're interested if you've
been around my channel for a while you
know that I love any conversation around
pregnancy and optimal nutrition so I was
excited to sit down with these two and
discuss the facts and also the
misleading information that's often
circulating in the health world right
now in this episode we dive into the
best dietary pattern for fertility and
pregnancy if fertility issues are on the
rise and what to do about it key
nutrients of focus during pregnancy and
plant-based considerations the trend to
consume organ Meats while pregnant their
thoughts on ancestral diets and if
there's a one-size-fits-all diet for
everyone hormonal birth control iron
deficiency placenta health and so much
more this episode is packed with
information and I honestly could have
gone on and on with them they are a
wealth of knowledge and we had so much
fun going back and forth so welcome to
the Ellen Fisher podcast let's get into
it
I love supporting an imamundi herbals
which is my favorite Apothecary that
carries organic wild crafted and
ethically grown Botanicals from
Elderberry syrup and adaptogenic
mushrooms to spirulina chocolate protein
teas and collagen booster powders they
are a super special company that uses
Fair Trade Practices Beyond organic
farming education and small farmers to
create remedies that benefit people from
all walks of life lately I've been
obsessed with their chocolate protein
superfood powder that I add to my
morning smoothies after a workout it's
designed using a blend of mostly South
American roots and seeds traditionally
used for energy strength stamina and
resilience this chocolate protein is a
wonderful addition to your smoothies or
you can even add it to your favorite
baked goods like muffins It's formulated
with pea protein rice protein and
pumpkin seed protein and it tastes
amazing it's adaptogenic energizing and
nutrient dense rich in plant-based
protein Prebiotic rich and may help
regulate blood sugar and assist in
treating adrenal fatigue you guys have
to try this yummy plant protein powder
and they also have so many other
remedies on their site which are formed
related for beauty immunity mood
elevation stress relief sleep body and
spirit and I find them to be the perfect
addition to my healthy daily routines
for my body inside and out so use my
code Ellen 20 for 20 off just click the
link in my show notes to get this deal
welcome to the podcast Whitney and Alex
I am so happy to have you here and it
sounds like you've had a great trip so
far you guys are such adventurous what
have you done for having us yeah we've
had a blast uh well we started off with
a sunny day in Wailea because it was a
little bit stormy over here
um I did yoga we did yoga an amazing
yoga class and a hike you're like I
hiked a little oh you want a hike yeah
and we did a yoga class it's like you're
getting all the things in we've been
popping all over the island you know
we're just soaking up as much as mental
health have you ever done the Enneagram
test like personality type test it's a
different type of yeah actually I feel
like everyone's done it but I don't
remember what I am well it's really
interesting because you guys sound like
you'd be adventurous just how much
you're like doing in these last few days
that you're here we definitely like to
maximize yeah our big things
so our work vacation yeah
so can you just explain a little bit for
those who are new to you guys and what
you do what is it that you guys do
what's your expertise and your
background yeah so we are both uh
registered dietitian nutritionist we
really came together well let's see I
had just had my son uh Whitney was
pregnant with her son we had actually
met at a conference gosh about like 13
years ago now liked each other instantly
became friends sort of talked throughout
social media at the internet Etc and
then we were really sort of you know
passing studies back and forth about
plant-based diets during pregnancy
during you know early childhood and sort
of felt like you know there really
wasn't a space where dietitians were
sharing this information and so we
decided to come together in 2018 and
start plant-based Juniors and our our
mission our ethos is really this idea
that we want all kids to be eating more
plants we look at survey data we know
that the vast majority of kids kids are
not consuming enough fruits enough
vegetables enough plant-based proteins
you know enough whole grains and really
sort of getting everyone to shift the
diet not only for human health but
really planetary health and sort of
trying to get as many people on board
and I feel like this sort of like age of
Pediatrics not a lot of people are
talking about plant-based diets and we
really want it to help fill the gaps
that's how plant-based Juniors came to
be our succinct mission is to help more
parents get more plants on the plate
awesome and a lot of what you guys talk
about is also fertility that's right
pregnancy so that's what we're going to
talk about today yeah so what is the
best diet for fertility what does the
research say yeah the research is pretty
overwhelming uh when it comes to
consistent dietary patterns that are
best for for fertility and that really
is a Mediterranean type of dietary
pattern so that can look like a lot of
different variations that can be a plan
exclusive diet that can be a plant
predominant diet that can be even a
pescetarian diet but really it's a diet
that's centered around fruits vegetables
legumes whole grains nuts unsaturated
fatty acids and really consuming more
protein from plant-based sources versus
animal sources
anything for you to say yeah and
definitely I think
um while we don't have a lot of
Interventional studies on specific diets
we do have a very consistent body of
research that is showing these
associations so there was one study out
of Harvard of over 17 000 women and the
closer they adhered to the so-called
pro-fertility diet which as Alex
described is high in unrefined
carbohydrates fiber rich carbohydrates
plant-based protein versus animal
protein and then unsaturated fatty acids
the women that most closely adhered to
this dietary pattern had a 66 percent
reduced risk of infertility so that's
amazing yeah and it's it's it's pretty
clear yeah it's in the evidence yeah one
thing I was going to say too about that
specific study is that they also found
that women had a higher chance of
fertility when they consumed iron from
either plant-based sources so non-heem
sources or from supplements which I
think sometimes you know we don't hear
enough of the benefit about plant-based
iron but that study specifically showed
a higher benefit in fertility with those
horses versus animal-based iron and is
there even enough research though to
give a confident answer I think there's
definitely enough to say this is the
dietary pattern that we know is
associated with not only improved
fertility also pregnancy I mean this is
sort of the same dietary pattern it
doesn't change really throughout the
lifespan I mean this is really the
consistence the consistent patterns that
we see are are the most beneficial
there's some Nuance of course and sort
of like where that that plant
predominancy to plant exclusive line
lies but for the most part I mean I
think I think any any arguments to the
contrary or any arguments against that
type of dietary pattern really isn't
evidence-based okay has there been a
rise in fertility issues it seems like
there has yeah yeah I mean I I think
that's definitely sort of where
headlines have led and I think there's a
lot of things to sort of unpack and
consider the first thing is that there
definitely has been an increased time to
conception so what that means is you
know we Define infertility as actively
trying during your active time of the
month uh for 12 months for women under
35 and that shortens to six months for
women over 35 so you know if you're
trying to get pregnant that's a really
long time to be wanting a baby and you
know not getting pregnant and not
considered to be infertile or having
that diagnosis of infertility and then
the other thing is too is that you know
fertility has really become more
medicalized in the last few decades you
know we IVF IUI various medications
these are all recent Technologies and so
we're also seeing increased numbers of
being able to track women who want to
use these these Technologies so you know
yes there is a slight increase in
increased time to conception but that
also has to do with other factors that
come into to being pregnant I like what
factors age is a big one you know I
think our our culture has shifted a lot
um most of us women especially are
becoming uh more educated which tends to
shift sort of the timeline for wanting
to have children and yeah the biggest
risk factor in infertility unfortunately
is age so you know when you're trying to
settle down and become pregnant and
you're 36 you know in in baby making
years you're you're a gestational I mean
you're a geriatric pregnancy you know
like it it's those are I don't love that
term no and I and I have that label too
yeah my doctor or my Midwife kept
referring to me as like a geriatric
pregnancy and I was like okay yeah you
know I know spring chicken but come on
it's true people are waiting longer to
till they're ready to have kids they
want to accomplish different things
first or like you said they're maybe
getting educated then they want to use
that education towards a career or a job
before they want to have kids where a
long time ago my grandparents were
having kids a lot younger yeah people
are like Alex said kind of to sum it up
as more people are seeking help for for
fertility so of course we're going to
see these numbers and we have more
options yeah I know that makes sense
like we didn't have all of these uh
reproductive Technologies several
decades ago right people weren't using
them as frequently so that's one measure
of infertility rates so it can seem like
we have this you know fertility crisis
but it's yeah we're measuring the cases
more and there are some you know
sub-optimal sort of considerations
lifestyle age you know stress is a big
one too and you know again with women
taking on sort of more responsibility
than maybe they used to a few
Generations ago all of those factors can
influence fertility that's really
interesting oh that's really hard to say
if it actually is on the rise or if it's
the way we're measuring it or if it's
the math that our population is just
more unhealthy generally totally I mean
babies later just it's complex what
about hormonal birth control do you
think that could affect fertility it
seems to me like the general
I don't know what you hear is like nope
it's perfectly healthy perfectly safe
anyone who says otherwise is quackery is
kind of what you hear yeah every single
person I know who's taken hormonal birth
control had really not fun effect did
not feel good or potentially maybe could
be correlating issues with fertility
down the road yeah obviously on their
own anecdotal experience not really sure
if that's connected but it seems to be
like a very common theme yet in the
medical world no one wants to
acknowledge it and it's very bizarre to
me yeah well we'll give you the evidence
base yeah I can answer tell me what the
evidence says anything you know the
anecdotes are there are often speak the
loudest people aren't coming online and
being like guess how many how much long
I took birth control for and how quickly
I got pregnant those aren't the stories
no that's true that's true so we hear
about the anecdotes and they speak
powerfully but the truth is well a lot
of these beliefs stem from high dose
hormonal birth control which is what
first came on the market and there
definitely wasn't association with
increased rates of infertility but um
the the most recent most comprehensive
evidence does show that low-dose
hormonal birth control does not reduce
fertility anymore compared to other
forms of contraception or to those who
are not taking it so when you're saying
other form of contraception do you mean
like condoms okay and condoms and such
yeah there was a recent um meta-analysis
that showed that there was about an 85
percent uh chance of successful
pregnancy following a discontinuation of
both forms of both of those types of
forms of contraceptives and that's about
the same as we see in the general
population we see about a 15 risk of
infertility just generally among women
okay I'm just very skeptical that
anything that stops our like biology
from ovulating couldn't have effects I
get it well and there is one thing to
say it does take about three months for
hormonal birth control to clear your
systems or there is certainly a delayed
time to conception in those first three
months after you discontinue it yeah and
that's the average time so maybe some
women it might take them longer I know
after I went off of birth control it
took me about a year to get pregnant my
second pregnancy I got pregnant the
first month so that's great it didn't
cause at least for me again yeah we're
talking about an anecdote yeah I know
because they're very like we just like
to be careful with like anyone yeah it
worked for me no but that's like very
responsible that's how it should be yeah
I think just so much of the human heart
drives towards anecdotes it's easy for
us it's easier for us to understand than
totally than research because we know
the average Layman doesn't know how to
read yeah read research you know so you
kind of have to just take someone's word
for it and there's a lot of different
things going back and forth I mean there
are endocrine disruptors that are
unfortunately in our environment that
may be affecting fertility things like
phthalates things like polycyclic uh
aromatic hydrocarbons I mean these are
all things that have been known to be
endocrine disruptors unfortunately these
environmental toxins also are stored in
adipose tissue so I mean there's there's
lots of factors and there's lots of
things that I think may be affecting
things it's just hard to sort of say at
like at this point in time this
specifically and this amount is going to
decrease by you know fertility by this
much yeah no it makes a lot of sense and
everyone should do what makes sense for
them but for me and myself it always
just didn't feel quite right and then
anyone that I know who has taken it has
had side effects and then when I hear
experts talking about it it's like no no
no there's nothing wrong with it so I
guess it's a healthy skepticism you know
and it it speaks a lot to other
movements in the health space about this
idea of what's natural yes to be right
and in some cases what's more natural
it's healthy for us and in some cases at
least with the current available
evidence that we have things that may
sound a little obscure or they're not
natural aren't necessarily okay like
what's a good example for that then well
if you want to talk about like the dose
makes the poison argument we could talk
about things like water where you know
it's healthy at a normal amount it's a
natural substance but in taking in an
excessive amount could have harmful
effects so there's lots of there's lots
of things like that yeah vitamin D I
mean we don't live natural lives most of
us are not here in the beautiful Tropics
where I live in St Louis above the 37th
parallel inside a lot of the time
because it's snowing all the time in the
winter I mean I just don't have access
to to vitamin D production in my skin
from the Sun so you know for me to be
able to get enough vitamin D I would
need to supplement or use fortified
Foods where that is not sort of the the
natural way or the way that we may be
all used to get vitamin D production but
it's also the safest and most effective
way for me and my family to get vitamin
D so you know I think there's I mean
there's definitely different arguments
we could say here's a natural version
but here's also in this sort of
practical world where our lives are
different you know I'm not outside all
the time with my baby on the back
because this is just the way that my
life is I work inside I work at a desk
and you know things I have to
factor in even though they might not be
the most quote unquote natural path yeah
and of course there's always pros and
cons so I think one of the biggest
things that people will bring up when
talking about strict plant-based diets
is the fact that if you need a
supplement it's not natural specifically
for B12 but you have to think about the
pros and cons so the pro is you're
taking B12 and then you're not eating an
excessive amount of animal products yes
maybe you could get B12 from those
products but you're also getting other
things that in excess are associated
with health problems so there's always
that that weighing yeah of issues I feel
like there's a healthy balance of like
going towards what's natural but then
also taking advantage of what we now
know and research and be able to utilize
these products that we could that can
make our lives better and easier one
last thing before we move on is the idea
of if it's natural it's the best way to
be is kind of a moot point we don't live
really in a natural environment again
you live pretty close to Nature here but
still most of us don't have so many
issues that our ancestors didn't we have
environmental contaminants that are in
our water that are in our soil we have
depleted soil we have all these issues
that uh prehistoric people didn't face
we have a climate crisis we have to
think about all these issues that go
beyond just is that the way people used
to eat yeah we are not those people
anymore our world is not that world yeah
and not something that Dr Gemma Newman
mentioned in the episode I did with her
was that people are always trying to go
back to the way that we used to eat and
used to live but she's like at which
part of the world though people know so
differently in different parts of the
world and they didn't actually live
longer or healthier lives anyways and we
were trying to get back to that such an
important argument and I I think we we
sort of romanticize this idea that like
Oh Our Ancestors exactly we're living
these like long beautiful healthy lives
like
like let's take a course in public
health because nutrient deficiencies
were rampant until we had a lot of these
you know fortification and
supplementation and enrichment programs
and you know just sort of the the
advances we've been able to make in not
only human health but especially when it
comes to you know infant and child
mortality has been dramatic over the
past 50 years and so I think that again
it's not to say that like so and so in
you know the early man was necessarily
healthier or better than we are now just
because it was a more natural way of
being they were doing what they needed
to do to just survive survive that's an
interesting point to bring up because
some people would look at that and say
yeah well we traded maybe we help
certain things like survival but we
aren't actually thriving in the way that
we used to like maybe there's all these
extra diseases that we have now that we
didn't use to have what do you think
about that
I think this is something you talked
about with Gemma Newman but that's just
not true I mean there's plenty of
evidence that early societies like the
Inuits perhaps had cardiovascular
disease and had some blockage in their
arteries yeah so we don't have evidence
to show that early man didn't suffer for
something yes there are lots of
lifestyle diseases that are newer but
they're multifactorial and they're not
necessarily based on nutrition alone and
this all ties into fertility because
fertility is part of our health yes so
what about other things that could
potentially cause fertility issues I
think what you said makes a lot of sense
about the way that we're tracking it and
women are having babies later wanting to
get pregnant later in life as opposed to
earlier in life but what about other
things like chemicals in our food is
there's any research on that to say that
that affects fertility yeah I mean I
think if any woman is struggling with
fertility issues the the first thing I
would do is talk about okay let's sort
of work on the things that we know we
have control over right so focusing on
diet first perhaps you know where where
you currently at where do we sort of
optimally need to be or can we help to
work on those gaps other lifestyle
factors you know exercise we talk a lot
about nutrition but having a healthy
body weight is really helpful when it
comes to fertility odds movement
reducing stress adequate sleep and these
are sort of all things that are sort of
in our our locus of control and then
also the reality too that there are
hormonal things that could be outside of
a woman's control too and I think
sometimes too we are so focused on
I think I think women especially feel
when they have a hard time getting
pregnant that they should feel like Ugh
there's all of this like wait on me and
all of this like societal blame or
personal blame it feels like a failing
and I think that's because you know for
a lot of women not every woman but
there's sort of always been this idea of
becoming a mother and so when there's a
struggle in getting to that place you
know it can feel really hard and then to
be told you know well it's because
you're doing this you're doing that I
think it really needs to be as
supportive as possible and also not
forgetting the guy yeah because you know
Tango yeah and often it always gets put
on yeah research has 25 of infertility
cases are due to male factors so yeah
that's a lot of the entire owners on
always or almost always falls on women
we all want a beautiful comfortable
clothing that's also flattering to your
body Indigo Luna is Yoga Chic these are
the types of clothes that you can rock
day to day whether you're at home doing
dishes going to your favorite yoga class
or shopping at the grocery store well at
least the grocery store part works for
Maui standards I'm not sure if anywhere
else it really works because here if you
see someone wearing heels and a pencil
skirt at the grocery store in Hawaii
it's clear that they don't live here
anyways Indigo Luna has ethically made
yoga wear swimwear Intimates and
loungewear they are slow fashion and
sustainably sourced with beautiful
simple shapes earthy colors and plant
dyes from recycled or organic materials
everything is cut sewn and dyed by a
loving human hand and they ensure that
every person involved in production
Works in comfortable safe conditions I
love supporting companies with conscious
practices it feels good to vote with my
dollars in this way and it really is a
win-win situation here because these
clothes feel so comfortable on my body
they hug and hold my curves just right
so under the code Ellen 10 for 10 off
your order or click the link in my show
notes yeah and we've been talking a lot
about sort of the the optimal foods but
we haven't really touched on the foods
that we also know are associated with
impaired fertility okay let's get into
that yeah especially um so diets rich in
refined carbohydrates added sugars and
you know again we look at sort of the
the average American diet I think it's
like 60 of of calories typically comes
from Ultra processed foods I mean can
you give some examples of specific foods
that are refined carbohydrates and sugar
I'm guessing I'm guessing you mean
processed sure right not whole fruit oh
sugar fruit yes so like yeah
carbohydrates basically when you take a
grain for example and you remove the
outer brand layer that's refining it the
outer brand layer is where the fiber is
so we're talking about things that have
been stripped of fiber they've been
stripped of their minerals so white
flour white pasta white rice a lot of
the packaged foods that you find like
serious bread
um yeah cereals if they're not oat based
or Corn based corn is actually a whole
grain surprise surprise yeah um so we're
talking about yeah yes fast food which
is the majority of the of the American
dietary beverages yeah and sugar is
we're talking mainly about refined sugar
condensed sugar so
um not the sugar that's found in fruit
which comes complex with all of those
things we talked about that are
beneficial in the grains the fiber
um the vitamins those things are all
removed when you make sugar from a fruit
yeah or make a fruit juice or something
like that yeah so these are the things
that have been associated with poor
health across the board but also with
specifically infertility I didn't know
that whole grains fiber rich
carbohydrates are actually associated
with increased chance of fertility and
improved pregnancy outcomes as well yeah
and you know I think this is really
important because when we sort of look
at at what people are eating
unfortunately it is a lot of these Foods
so just sort of cleaning up or replacing
I should say these Ultra processed foods
with more of the the fruits the
vegetables whole grains I mean even if
we're not taking it all the way sort of
to a plan exclusive model
it has huge ramifications when it comes
to overall fertility especially taking
out other things that we know may be
harmful in fertility especially in men
High intakes of red meat have been
associated with risk of fertility in men
also processed meats and then trans fats
in both men and women unsaturated
fatsaturated has been associated with a
reduced risk of fertility
reduced risk of fertility increased risk
of infertility increased risk yes but
like Alex said because of the nutrients
that we know are high in diets that are
based largely upon meat and processed
Meats though the research doesn't show
specifically for women it's likely that
that would be harmful for fertility too
since it is shown in the research on men
if we instead of focus on what we're
trying to limit and focus on what we
want to increase in the diet there's
ample research showing the benefits of
diets high in monounsaturated fat and
polyunsaturated fats specifically DHA
both for fertility but also during
pregnancy specifically for infant brain
development so really ramping up those
nutrients which then in turn kind of
decreases the saturated fat in the diet
okay and again if when you're focusing
on all of these foods like the whole
grains fruits and vegetables you
naturally will be limiting your
saturated fat yeah and you know if if I
was a woman or a man listening to this I
think you know when I'm advising clients
the first thing I would say is okay
let's look at sort of where we currently
are and and where are sort of maybe some
small changes we can start with and then
sort of build from there because there
are so many things and I think sometimes
especially when we're trying to hit this
this goal of becoming pregnant it can
feel really overwhelming and then
stressful which can maybe you know in
impair fertility and so I think it's
like taking really manageable steps uh
for overall health and you know like we
keep sort of you know harping on too yes
we're talking specifically about
fertility but so many of these things
are also the same when it comes to
pregnancy when it comes to you know
overall optimal diet to reduce risk of
chronic disease it's not like I mean
things definitely change a little During
certain life stages but for the most
part we're talking about the very same
dietary pattern for overall when I'm
counseling a client I I like to try to
get them away from focusing on
quantitative measures of health and
really focus on qualitative and
specifically what we want to add to the
diet so instead of the focus just being
like I need to limit saturated fat down
to this number it's like well how can I
add more of these beneficial fats that I
know are going to be helpful for
improving my fertility chances or
improving my pregnancy like how can I
get more avocados in my diet where can I
add more nuts and seeds and so kind of
from this perspective of abundance
versus a perspective of what needs to be
limited yeah and that's helpful not just
physically but also mentally yeah
emotionally so emotionally such a huge
aspect of any health but definitely when
you're in a sensitive State totally I
love how supportive you are being and
how just encouraging that you guys are
about this topic because like you said
it can be a sensitive time especially if
everyone around them is easily getting
pregnant left and right and how
discouraging that must be for those who
are going through that and just trying
to figure it out so that is super
important and then the other thing you
brought up about polyunsaturated fats
can we talk a little bit about that
because sometimes it's kind of all
lumped together like are we talking
Whole Food Polly and saturated fat are
you talking canola oil you know what I'm
saying like all that that aspect the
research is mainly specifically on the
long chain omega-3 fatty acids DHA so
it's really mono specifically for
talking about fertility
um and pregnancy DHA is primarily found
in in Seafood this is because fish
consume microalgae and it accumulates in
their tissues so the main dietary source
for most people would be fish but people
following plant predominant plant-based
diets or those who simply don't like to
eat fish can easily obtain DHA through
an algae based supplement the other
thing is our body does make DHA from the
plant-based omega-3 fatty acid ala alpha
linolenic acid which is found in things
like chia seeds and flax and walnuts the
conversion rate is low though and
perhaps too low to support optimal
amounts specifically during pregnancy
and lactation which is why a ACOG as
well as the AAP recommend that if you
don't consume fish during these periods
of time that you should supplement with
200 to 300 milligrams a day interesting
and it makes sense like everything's
about covering your bases for everybody
for me myself and all five of my births
and pregnancy I never took an algae
supplement I always just ate plenty of
chia seeds flax seeds all that walnuts
eating lots of that and for me I've just
always been like very good at eating
super Whole Food space like very
consistent in my life and the way that I
live and so I always just trust in
myself that I I feel I felt good I
didn't feel like I needed it but again
I'm not the dietitians here like giving
out Mass advice so it makes sense to
have both options I think like
individuality well and you know
remembering too that these these
recommendations from from ACOG are
really towards again sort of the the
average American and when we look at
survey data of what is being consumed
it's not copious amounts of seeds or
have seeds or walnuts you know and and I
think these these guidelines are really
to sort of you know ensure optimal
prenatal Health um but also optimal
infant health because so much of what
happens uh in so much of the baby is
sort of determined by Mom's nutrition uh
in utero so it's the main reason then
not to just recommend oh make sure to
eat a quarter cup of hemp seeds every
day because the conversions you know you
just don't know exactly where the
conversion lies so just to be safe take
a supplement because for me we're just
we go through so much hemp seeds in our
family and we're like yeah it also might
make more sense economically for someone
to to buy a supplement versus depending
on how expensive you're having yeah and
it depends every day is a lot we just
add a lot in our smoothies and I have it
in breakfast in our oatmeal every
morning in our pancakes so yeah yeah
some of us we don't know you know is
there inter-indiven inter individuality
with conversion rates that hasn't been
explored that much either maybe people
who are following predominant or fully
plant-based diets have higher conversion
rates yes this is where
um you know we've talked about this
before not here but off camera
um the the macro aspects of diets that
are Universal which is like these
dietary patterns that are generally
associated with health for everyone and
then the micro aspects of Health which
may have a little bit of variability
from person to person again these the
ACOG recommendation is to meet the needs
of the general public of people who are
not necessarily consuming the most
nutrient dense diets just to make sure
that they are getting DHA one way or
another yeah which makes sense it should
be and and because the conversion it
could be so variable and because we
don't have exact amounts we can't say a
quarter cup of let's say chia seeds it
hasn't been tested exactly yeah yeah so
it's like we know the average conversion
rate of ala to Tha yeah we know what
that is yeah we don't know what it is
for you and we don't know what it would
be if you're eating a ton yeah totally
no and that's why what you guys do was
so important because there aren't a lot
of people out there giving the research
evidence-based information for people to
know to take it and know what to do with
it yeah I think that's you start with
the guidelines yeah and then you figure
out how that fits for your family yeah
for sure okay so I want to go back to
something you mentioned about weight and
being an optimal weight can you talk a
little bit more about that does it that
mean if you're like under a certain
weight or over a certain weight what
does that mean for fertility yeah yeah
so uh there's there's an association
with both being underweight and with
having overweight or obesity when it
comes to both fertility and pregnancy
when you are underweight you may have a
harder time becoming pregnant we need to
have adequate uh adipose tissue Adept
adequate body fat to be able to support
growing a fetus and really when it comes
to pregnancy that is the concern with
women who are underweight is having a
small for gestational age infant with
women who are overweight but really with
women who have obesity for ability also
plays a role it's it's why a lot of
times when there is a struggle to become
pregnant if a woman does have or does
present with obesity
a lot of times the recommendation is to
try weight loss to help with fertility
and then when it comes to pregnancy
specifically
um also Having excess weight gain during
pregnancy is associated with increased
risk of gestational diabetes
preeclampsia having a large for
gestational infant so there definitely
is sort of this optimal weight range
that we would like to see for both
fertility and pregnancy but that's also
not to say that you cannot become
pregnant or have a healthy pregnancy
sort of in either end it's just sort of
where the the recent currently is and
you know wait wait is one factor when it
comes to overall health because this can
be a really sensitive subject yeah for
for most women absolutely yeah so it can
be a very sensitive topic but it is
helpful really helpful for people to
know I think a lot of people don't even
know that yeah well yeah I just I like
you said kind of to synthesize it like
the the bottom line is losing weight can
be helpful for improving fertility and
you can have fertility and a healthy
pregnancy if you are in a larger body it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're in
infertility is is in um in question and
this is really because what Alex said
the excess adipose tissue can lead to
some sort of metabolic derangements
things like insulin resistance and these
things are are associated with increased
in fertility and those are improved by
weight loss and that's one of the
beauties of eating a Whole Foods
plant-based diet is that you really do
get to eat until you're totally
satisfied you listen to it actually is
very amazing how the body works because
when you're eating a diet rich in water
and fiber and all those nutrients it
fills you up and you naturally know what
to stop but if you're eating a diet rich
in real Ultra processed foods or super
high calorie animal-based products as
the majority of your diet you end up
having to calorie restrict and by doing
that that's where you end up going back
and forth about which which way is your
your weight but when you're eating so
consistently Whole Foods plant base and
the majority of your Foods or food is
from Whole Foods maintaining your
optimal weight is one of I think one of
the best things or one of the easiest
factors of eating Whole Foods
plant-based definitely goes back to that
fiber it helps you stay Fuller longer
you can better sense your satiety cubes
so yeah well then you know if especially
if we're talking about uh fertility and
pregnancy too if we are counseling on on
weight loss it would also want to be
done within sort of the concept of a
nutrient dense diet yeah
um not anything to lose weight yeah yeah
but meaning too like there are lots of
ways to lose weight they just also don't
coincide with being optimal for
fertility and so it's really healthy yes
sort of this like you know double-edged
approach and it wanting to ensure both
and you know the last thing I'll just
say is that there definitely is some
controversy in the literature when it
comes to women who women with obesity
and weight gain weight loss during
pregnancy so there are a lot of
individual factors that you'd want to
consider and we would really recommend
working closely with your doctor with
your Midwife to figure out sort of what
is going to be optimal for you yeah and
to be clear like you said weight is just
one factor because it's going to be at a
healthy quote-unquote weight but not be
healthy on the inside absolutely and you
know the opposite can be true too where
you're eating really well but you might
not be in this quote unquote yeah you
know optimal weight and so there's
variations here but what's amazing about
like eating Whole Foods is that it
becomes it's kind of a little bit
seamless whereas just the life that I
knew before eating plant-based was a lot
of just like well after I had gone
through puberty all of a sudden I
couldn't couldn't just eat Doritos and
snicker bars that break in high school
every day I was like oh shoot I'm
actually starting to gain weight here
and so then I had to take into this
measurement because I didn't know how to
eat well no one taught me how to eat
well you know my parents were doing the
best that they knew at the time we had a
lot of fruits and vegetables in the
house but we also had a lot of you know
a lot of junk too yeah so that's when
people start not knowing what to do
because they just want to you know they
want to feel good in their body yeah not
just Weight Wise but feeling good and so
then weight or restriction starts coming
in with food and that's just not
sustainable so like you said when you oh
you can do all these different types of
diets to lose weight but is that going
to be sustainable and healthy for you
that's the key difference yeah blanket
recommendation to lose weight can result
in you perhaps increasing your chance of
fertility thanks to the weight loss but
decreasing your chance of fertility due
to the nutrients that you're consuming
so if you're not doing it with these
Quality Foods these foods that we know
are associated with improved fertility
outcomes then it kind of might even
negate the weight loss or set you up for
other long-term Health complications
that's awesome that's so well said yeah
this is what I was trying to say
yeah I get it I mean and I really relate
to that too because back in high school
you know when all of the societal
pressure really starts to Bear Down
regarding Aesthetics and weight and
you're like calorie counting all that
matter is that you keep the calories
down it doesn't matter what you're
eating that's not a recipe for long-term
Health yeah exactly and then there's
other things that come into play too
after puberty like maybe acne yeah all
these different things you're like what
is going on and maybe I just try to not
eat here and some some women are still
trying to figure it out so many women
like get into their adulthood and still
going what do I do to feel well and so
that's why what you guys do and you know
sharing about eating Whole Foods is so
amazing and so important well and this
is a whole you know other thing but we
just we don't we don't teach these
things you know like I mean there is
such a lack of
um not even just nutrition but culinary
education uh when it comes to kids when
it comes to you know really
understanding and navigating this world
and so I think that there are there are
so many factors of why unfortunately a
lot of us get to adulthood and it's like
I don't I don't know what to do before I
got into Pediatrics I worked for a long
time in University Athletics and I had
so many students who would be you know
18 19 on their own for the first time
and would be like
I I don't know how to nourish myself I
don't know how to cook I don't even know
how to prepare things like what do you
mean you want me to make pasta like I I
boil the water like I know how to make
easy mac and you know unfortunately I
think there is just such a a societal
lack of
perhaps even how it used to be of really
like passing down some of these culinary
skills some of these nutrition know-hows
throughout the generations yeah and that
does take into account like okay maybe
there's there are certain things that we
did in the past that we need to get back
to Our Roots a little bit more growing
our own food things like that getting
more connected to our food well and it's
time I mean you know we we've also
evolved into for a lot of American
families and I say American just because
I know the data well for that uh dual
income households you know and so where
time is of you know sort of the essence
and uh this is why there is such a big
rise too in inconvenience you know foods
but also you know other Technologies and
you know I think about myself too like
my husband works I work it does take
effort and it does take time to to
prepare certain things and to be in the
kitchen with my kids and to cook
together and that is a huge value for me
and so I I make the time and the effort
to do it but I also understand that
there are so many factors and so many
lives where that feels like just one
more thing to have to get done yeah and
so I'm not trying to place blame when I
say that there is sort of this lack of
of overall sort of culinary Christian
education but it's yeah it's it's sort
of this dichotomy of a lot of us are
raised on more Ultra processed
convenience Foods why that is and then
also that sort of loss that happens with
understanding how to now be on your own
and and cook and provide and just the
time yes like you said with how busy
life is I definitely can attest to that
and when I had one
parents would kind of be like oh it's so
hard to you know make foods from scratch
I don't know how to do it I'd be like oh
it's so easy and then I had two and then
three and then four and then five and
I'm like oh my gosh we are going through
so much hummus because we make so much
hummus you know just so much hummus like
four cans of beans that we drain and
rinse and may come because we go through
so much that I want it to be really
nutritious I don't want to just buy a
store-bought one that has ingredients
that I don't think are optimal for our
family so we make it from scratch but
we're doing this like like twice a week
week so much hummus because there's so
much of us yeah that's just an example
we're not just eating it's a lot of time
to make time yeah we're out of hummus
again
so that is an example okay so moving on
let's talk a little bit about this kind
of rise this increase in talk on
um organ meats and that for pregnancy
and fertility there's a mini documentary
that features the psychiatrist Paul
saladino and love that you mentioned
he's a psychiatrist but really important
thing it's important to mention yeah I
mean a lot a lot of people just want to
say oh yeah Dr Paul saladino but like he
is a psychiatrist that's really
important to preface like not saying
that's not important it is but I don't
know anyways at this point your
expertise is not nutritious yeah it's
just yeah it's really important
um so this mini documentary is coming
out talking about organ meats and the
importance of you know a really rich
animal food based diet for pregnancy
fertility it even went into this
specific example which just kills me you
guys it showed this placenta saying that
this put this one placenta is like not
healthy looking it's dull it doesn't
have all the vibrant veins and colors
and that was from a vegan diet and then
or or like a non-animal based diet I
don't know if they specifically said
vegan or vegetarian I can't remember but
the other the other one was this vibrant
full healthy placenta and the Midwife or
whoever was narrating was like the the
difference was so Stark from the animal
base and I just like that anecdote just
really kills me because if you want to
talk anecdotes like all five of my
bursts like I literally have it
documented on video footage like if
we're just gonna play Devil's Advocate
with the with the anecdotes here we're
the most vibrant colorful placentas that
even after my first one I think my
Midwife was my first Midwife back when I
was in California said well whatever you
did was working for you because back
when I I've been you know vegan for 16
years now so it definitely wasn't quite
it wasn't on the upright is back when I
had started and so my Midwife was
supportive but she's like oh I don't
know and I'm like no I got this I'm so
healthy like don't worry about me and
then when my baby was born she's like
whoa that is the healthiest placenta
I've ever seen she literally says that
the proof is in the place yeah yeah okay
what kind of diet was that vegan there's
so many different ways to eat totally I
think we need to call for placental
photos and we can just like start
swapping them around I've got mine it's
also bright and red and beautiful
um just this whole thing is so silly
we've got so many thoughts yeah where to
begin okay I think the first thing uh
let's start with why consuming organ
Meats is silly to begin with one we
don't have a lot of data showing that
women were consuming tons of organ meat
yes we have
um evidence that people have consumed
meat since throughout the course of
history and prehistoric times and likely
did consume um some organ Meats but this
idea that pregnant women or women for
fertility were consuming diet space
largely on these things is just there's
no evidence for that the second thing is
the potential harms of consuming organ
Meats organ meats are concentrated
sources of some of these Nutri trans and
some of them that have upper tolerable
levels that we want to stay below so one
of those is pre-formed vitamin A which
an increased intake of or an excessive
intake in pregnancy has been linked to
birth defects so that's one of the
nutrients that all of the major health
organizations are like don't get too
much preformed vitamin A during
pregnancy
um preformed is retinol retinol just to
be correct so that's retinol that's the
kind that's found in animal foods and
then the other source of vitamin A is
carotenoids which is found in plant
foods which there is not an upper
tolerable level for because our body
excretes any excess we have a very like
finely tuned system where we can meet
all of our vitamin A needs with plant
foods and if we consume a lot of it no
no harm no foul we get rid of it so why
do people think then that like the
vitamin A the real quote-unquote real
vitamin A is what they call it from
animal Foods why do they think that
that's better than I mean it's it's it's
more bioavailable as far as absorption
right so you know I think I think a lot
of the arguments with organ Meats at
least what I've seen and again just to
be clear too there is no research
showing that consuming organ Meats
during pregnancy or infertility is
beneficial or has you know increased to
help uh with when becoming pregnant or
having a better uh pregnancy outcome
there's nothing on that there is there's
nothing no and that actually the only
research regarding organ meats and
pregnancy is suggesting that women avoid
them for this reason because of the
vitamin A beef liver three ounces
contains more than two times the upper
tolerable level of vitamin A for
pregnancy wow it's very risky wow
additionally the livers are
detoxification system this is where we
take environmental contaminants heavy
metals and we get and we process them
and try to make them less harmful to our
body so all of these things can be found
in the liver in an animal's liver this
is not necessarily it it's a great
source great source of certain nutrients
but it's not the only source and it's
definitely not the safest Source
the kind of argument I've heard about
the liver thing is that because it is a
recycling it's excreting it so it's not
actually a story it's not a storage
organ yes it is it's going through there
yeah yeah at any given time yeah it may
be found in there yeah yeah I mean the
liver is an excellent source of iron so
that tends to be the the argument the
big push you know especially knowing
that you know almost 30 percent of women
according to survey data are iron
deficient in their last trimester of
pregnancy there seems to be this sort of
movement around organ Meats specifically
during pregnancy and in early infancy
too because of the iron argument but
because it is such a wonderfully
concentrated source of iron it is also a
wonderfully concentrated source of all
of these other things that we really
would want to be a lot more cautious of
it especially in periods of growth
pregnancy Early Childhood so you know I
I definitely hear the argument around
liver or organomets as sort of an
iron-rich Source we can't deny that but
I also think we have to really take into
account of what are the other
considerations for that and you know one
again two there's no precedence for for
why this would be an optimal food during
fertility and pregnancy and also there
is real concern around excessive retinol
intake and vitamin A is so concentrated
not only in liver but also things like
cod liver oil and and both of those are
recommended to really not be consumed
during pregnancy you know and it's
getting back to the foods that we know
support fertility if we can find these
nutrients and foods that are actually
are associated with beneficial fertility
outcomes why would we turn to something
that has no data showing that it's
beneficial and potentially all of these
harmful side effects why wouldn't we go
get our vitamin A from mangoes and sweet
potatoes and things that actually take a
very small amount to meet your vitamin A
needs why wouldn't we get iron from
things like whole grains and legumes and
nuts and seeds which are also going to
be high in unsaturated fatty acids which
are also going to be high in fiber
it's just kind of nonsensical can I say
too I've been looking a little at like
some of these uh various individuals who
who promote sort of this idea and and
yeah I mean it feels it really calls to
that sort of like you know appeal to
Nature you know the sort of like I think
innateness that sometimes we want to
have to be like oh this must be how our
ancestors ate I mean I know especially
for when I was pregnant I I did feel so
close to Nature because I was literally
growing life yeah and I think so many
women resonate with this idea of like I
just want to sort of shut everything out
I want to like dig into the Earth and
get back to like sort of like this this
Vibe and I think that it is a really
sexy appeal to then feel like oh yeah
I'm Gonna Get You Know sort of Nature's
multivitamin which I've heard liver be
called and and eat it and you know sort
of having this like you healing
ceremonial like I'm eating this this
organ of this animal I feel like those
are sort of these calls and it I
understand this appeal I get it but when
we look at the evidence we look at the
science we look at sort of the not only
the efficacy but also potential harms I
I definitely don't feel comfortable as a
dietitian especially one who specializes
in fertility pregnancy Early Childhood
to feel like this is a safe option
I mean and just to keep compounding on
all of the issues we're not even talking
about the environmental implications of
everyone thinking that they need to eat
an excessive amount of meat and organs
we wouldn't be able to produce enough or
live there's one for one specific
organism the amount of cow they'd have
to start killing cows just for the liver
because there wouldn't be enough demand
for the there'd be more demand for the
actual liver than the rest exactly and
we would have to have so many more cows
not logical yeah it's kind of similar to
The Fish recommendation of women
consuming or actually really I think
they recommend it for all Health two
servings of fish per week if people
actually did that
um the oceans would be completely fished
out so we we can't think in such a micro
way about these things and then you see
with these uh people promoting this are
people actually eating the liver no
they're turning them into supplements
and people are selling them and so back
to your documentary that documentary is
made by a supplement company their main
Drive is to sell their liver supplements
wow that's interesting I mean there's
always gonna be amazing questions just
anecdotally right like or Devil's
Advocate again like every documentary
they are going to have some kind of
motive but you're right it isn't
necessarily to like sell something after
that but I don't know selling something
isn't necessarily a negative thing
because everyone has to make money on
the things they're passionate about
that's part of how you can continue to
spread the word on something you're
passionate about but it does come into
play a little bit of bias because it
gives you a moment of pause yeah just
consider what's your agenda with this
with this so-called documentary yeah
even if this was optimal right let's
just say that this is optimal it's not
optimal when we consider where we are
currently in sort of the history of
human health the responsibility that we
have especially when we're talking about
you know bringing in more more people
you know raising the Next Generation
to ignore the ecological impact to not
consider both the environment and the
impact that these food choices have is
just
I mean it's it's elitist it's just yeah
responsible I mean it's just it just I
think really also falls on deaf ears you
know sort of like where we need to go in
the conversations we need to be having
and some of these ancestral sort of type
of conversations one they're not truly
aligned with what we know to be sort of
the quote-unquote paleo diet and also
it's just not even if again if it was
optimal it's just not optimal we
consider both planetary and human health
but that's even if it was optimal even
if it was even if it was yeah but it's
not what about high the high raw dairy
type of recommendation in that yeah as
well like gallons though like like yeah
pints of it every day oh wow
um in regards to Dairy intake at all and
its impact on fertility it looks to be
possibly neutral there's a lot of
variability in the research about the
kinds of dairy whether low fat or high
fat and how it impacts fertility
um at this point the current
recommendation is dairy intake is likely
has a neutral effect on fertility what
concerns me about what the ancestral
communities are are supporting regards
to Dairy is this idea that pregnant
women should be consuming raw milk which
has a really high food safety risk of
bacterial contamination so it's just
it's not a safe recommendation
um is that because
though is there is there all an
understanding that maybe the raw milk
would be better than pasteurized and if
you if they like go and Trust the source
and they know that they're doing things
really well they're not doing it at a
massive amount like to me that does make
sense I mean I'd start with like
we don't have a ton of data saying that
milk intake period is all that
beneficial so yeah I don't know if you
even need to know aside from that right
just like the Sandy aspects well yeah I
guess if you were there and they Milk
The Cow and you drink it immediately
after
um you can have a high likelihood that
you're not going to have a bacterial
contamination it's the time after
um that it's sitting there for
unpasteurized products that bacteria can
quickly multiply into the point where
you can't smell it you can't taste it
you can't see it yep um it's a risk and
it's and and why and why and then so
then it goes back to why why would you
take that risk and it's that's how we
feel a lot about a lot of foods that are
considered like no-nos during pregnancy
are they going to cause a problem are
you going to get sick
probably not but there's a risk so why
take that risk if it doesn't have
um a major benefit that you're going to
write obviously they're putting forth
that there is a major benefit we'd argue
that the research doesn't agree with
that it's probably neutral
um and if we're talking about the main
nutrients that you would find in milk
we're talking about saturated fat we're
talking about protein let's go back
again to the the foods and the patterns
that are associated with decreased risk
of infertility
those are unsaturated fats not saturated
fats those are
plant-based proteins not animal based
proteins so it's just it doesn't align
with the research it's potentially risky
it's starting to sound like the organ
meat again right yes like sure we want
fat and we want protein but there are
other places we can get it from foods
that are more aligned with a pro
fertility diet a healthy pregnancy diet
and better for the environment and
better for the environment not to
mention um cow yeah and the cow
specifically we haven't cut we covered
such saturated fat a little bit in
regards to fertility but there's pretty
strong data in regards to pregnancy that
diets high in saturated fat are
associated with poor pregnancy outcomes
so a high saturated fat diet is going to
be increase your risk of gestational
diabetes increase your risk of
preeclampsia
so there's just lots of reasons why
these Foods aren't ideal and what does
the research say about plant-based or
plant predominant diets for fertility in
particular does it has it studied that
much and is it is it healthful is it
optimal yeah I mean you know I I would
definitely consider a a Mediterranean
type of dietary pattern of plant
predominant pattern I think that's also
pretty consistent with the quote-unquote
fertility diet that we keep referencing
using nurses Health Data out of Harvard
so you know I think there is pretty
strong evidence to show that a plant
predominant style dietary pattern is is
likely optimal for fertility as far as a
plant exclusive or a vegan diet we don't
have data to show that
it is the best we don't have data to
show that it is maybe even more optimal
than a plant predominant diet we do know
that it can be safe we do know that it
can be effective uh for for both
fertility and for pregnancy that is also
the statement of the American Academy I
always say American The Academy of
nutrition and dietetics
um but you know to say that we actually
have specific concrete studies showing
that we just don't currently have that
research yeah there's just been no
studies on fertility and vegan or
vegetarian diets can we talk about why
too I mean I think this is also really
important to understand study design
in in order to have some type of trial
where we say okay this group does this
this group does this we have to be
willing to alter one of the controls and
so you know especially in women who are
trying to become pregnant to say hey
we're not sure about this we want to
test it we're not going to put women at
risk of things that we're not sure of
that this is absolutely true in
pregnancy even more you know we're never
going to give women raw milk and then
not give women raw milk and see what
happens I mean that is just completely
unethical it would never pass uh
institutional review board so a lot of
the research that we do have when it
comes to both fertility and pregnancy is
observational in nature there's
obviously going to be you know pros and
cons with using that kind of data but I
think it's important to say you know
just because we don't have concrete
evidence on this specific thing doesn't
mean that we can't see patterns and
especially again like I was talking
about with that plant predominancy I
mean that that is the common thread
throughout the vast majority of
fertility research there is a little bit
of research on pregnancy and some in
some pregnancy outcomes in regards to
specifically vegan and vegetarian diet
specifically for preeclampsia there was
one study done on women at the farm you
may have heard of the farm it was it's a
vegan community in rural Tennessee who
follows a very uh appropriately planned
vegan diet they are eating basically
according to all the guidelines of how
you should either supplementing so this
is a really good group to look at for
for different Health outcomes and out of
775 women only one had pre-eclampsia of
the whole and what's the what did you
say the state the averages I think it's
about 10 to maybe 15
um and also I should say too yeah
preeclampsia is the leading cause of
both maternal and infant mortality it is
it is an issue yes in developing our low
income countries as well it is also
definitely a concern here in in higher
income countries I mean it really is I
think probably one of the the riskiest
concerns when it comes to pregnancy
there's a lot of factors diet is just
one of them age
um you know number of pregnancies so you
tend to have a higher risk the the more
babies that you have if you're carrying
twins or triplets rate goes up weight
can be a factor so you know diet is one
factor but yeah the again the
observational research that we do have
showing that you know high fiber vegan
diet may be possibly beneficial is yeah
and this is not to be confused with like
a processed vegan diet because there's
so many different ways to eat correct
vegan right you can eat uh Oreos and
chips all day and vegan burgers or you
can eat whole plant foods with beans and
sweet potatoes and lots of avocado and
Tahini and hemp seeds lots of hemp seeds
yeah
and fruit and vegetables all that so so
what is exactly to be clear because we
never really preface what does plant
predominant mean versus exclusively
plant-based yeah so uh when it comes to
fertility plant predominant can mean
there's there's no sort of specific
defined percentage
um really in the research it's anywhere
from 75 to up to 85 maybe even 90
percent of a whole food plant-based diet
within some allocation for animal Foods
I would say if we're talking about the
optimal sort of plant predominant
fertility diet based on the research and
looking at Health alone it would be uh
sort of probably an 85 percent
plant-based whole food diet with an
allocation for things like eggs and fish
because both of those things have shown
to be possibly beneficial not only in
pregnant I mean infertility but also in
pregnancy again there are some
variations sort of what that specific
percentage is but when we talk about
where we currently are in in sort of the
standard American diet to even just
let's say a 75 percent plant predominant
diet I mean we're miles apart and so
really I think trying to sort of go back
to our our overall ethos or overall
mission is really trying to shift as
much as we can to just say
yeah where where can we meet you know
and and knowing the the benefits that
can happen again for all stages of life
but really specifically for fertility
and pregnancy to getting people to be
you know at least 75 predominant from
there you know there's a lot of I think
nuance and variance and what works
individually and when you say 75 does
that mean 75 of calories or 75 of the
plate like physical plate because a lot
of times people can think oh yeah I eat
mostly plants but then when you break it
down it looks like mostly plants of
calories because it'll be like oh this
much of my plate has you know I guess
and this but most of the calories are
coming from meat or dairy yes we would
say of calories and again it's not a
thing that can necessarily be
specifically Quantified when when we
talk about a plant predominant diet we
often talk about how it can look
different for different families the
whole idea is a diet based mainly around
whole plant foods and for everyone
that's going to look different for a
variety of factors for from health
conditions to socioeconomic status like
it it varies a lot the goal is that we
should all be eating more plant Foods
let's all get as close as we can let's
all reduce our meat intake as much as we
can and we really like this term because
it's inclusive and if we want to meet
our massive Global goals of of halting
climate change of meeting the un's
sustainable health goals we're not going
to be able to do this if people are only
meeting certain expectations of
perfection so we like to put forth this
term and say take it how it works for
you it's a it's an open door to start
exploring a plant-based diet and
whatever works for you and then find
where you fall there because we want
more people eating more plants and less
and less meat when we don't we don't
want to exclude anyone because they
can't meet a certain ideal totally
totally and I think it's helpful too to
explain that in addition to what you
just said the Cal calorie thing so
people can know okay where do I start
how do I go there instead of replacing
your meat with broccoli that's not going
to work like you need the broccoli but
you need to replace the meat with
something more calorically dense like a
calorically dense plant food like sweet
potatoes or beans and things like that
so absolutely which is where people have
missteps yeah when they start
plant-based diets is is missing out on
these key nutrients and I'm thinking the
diet isn't working for them when really
it's just hasn't been appropriately
planned yeah well and especially in both
in pregnancy where we we do need higher
levels of protein so we can't just sort
of cut out the the traditional sort of
meat and then replace it only with you
know vegetables or fruits we really need
to be focusing too on legumes on on
plant-based proteins on tofu on tempeh
to try to help meet that that need
during pregnancy perfect and what are
the key nutrients of focus for pregnancy
and also for plant-based considerations
yeah I mean the the first one to
consider is just overall energy intake
calorie series needs increased by about
340 calories in the second trimester and
about 450 calories in the third
trimester no one needs to be calorie
counting this really just sort of looks
like maybe additional larger snack or
mini meal in the second trimester and
then in the third trimester maybe having
larger portions in addition to sort of
that that snack or additional meal to
help meet goals but really that would be
sort of the the biggest consideration
protein like I said you know 25 grams
which is about 70 to 80 grams for the
average woman to help meet for for
protein needs fat and carbohydrates they
remain about the same as the general
population in terms of needs but for the
healthiest pregnancy outcomes again you
want to be focusing on more whole grain
more fiber-rich carbohydrate sources and
of course the more unsaturated fatty
acids so the monounsaturated fats that
are found in plant foods and nuts and
seeds and as well as the polyunsaturated
long chain omega-3 fatty acid DHA again
which I think we talked enough about
that one are there any other specific
supplements you do recommend or don't
recommend in pregnancy that you're
seeing yeah I mean the the other the
other big nutrient during pregnancy is
ensuring adequate intake of folate folic
acid this is why one of the
recommendations set forth is for women
who are thinking about becoming pregnant
is to start a prenatal the big
difference between a prenatal and a
multivitamin is the fact that a prenatal
specifically is probably going to have
higher intake levels of folic acid
iodine and iron to help meet those needs
during pregnancy
um so the the reason that we want to
really focus on folate on folic acid is
because
um this is sort of the not getting
enough of that nutrient in the first 12
weeks or so of pregnancy that's when the
neural tube forms uh in the infant and
not having enough folate folic acid can
increase risk of something called spina
bifida which is where the neural tube
doesn't close completely and because
some women do not know they're pregnant
until maybe further in when you know the
brain the spinal cord is developing it
might be too late it's not a nutrient
that you could take more of later in
pregnancy to correct that once it's it's
formed its form so
um we we do want to ensure adequate
intake of a folate folic acid that is a
supplement that I took for all of my
pregnancies in the very beginning my
husband used to be a vitamins manager at
a health food shop for many years back
when they lived in California so he got
like very up in the understanding of
yeah supplements and he's like this is
one you definitely need to take it's
been like one of the most well
researched supplements for pregnancy so
every single one I took it even though
he also said in addition that like
plant-based diets are the ones that are
the most rich in folate which is great
but like the added Assurance because it
is so strongly associated with straw
like good brain development and
everything like that if we want to talk
about healthy brain development we
should be talking about B12 iron and
choline which are all nutrients that we
should really focus on during pregnancy
for a plant-based diet as we discussed
that means B12 should definitely be
supplemented not just for exclusively
plant-based women research has shown
that people falling vegetarian and even
semi-vegetarian diets may be at risk of
B12 deficiency this also goes for anyone
with absorption issues in the stomach
someone who's had gastric bypass surgery
or somebody who perhaps is even on ppis
and might not have enough stomach acid
B12 is recommended to be to be
supplemented and in high dose so there's
a lot of confusion about how much B12
especially for plant-based pregnancies
is a appropriate the absorption of B12
in a single dose goes down with an
increasing amount so you can't just take
the RDA it's actually recommended to
take about 250 micrograms if you're
going to take a single dose and most
prenatal multivitamins do not contain
that amount so most people will likely
want an additional B12 supplement on top
of their prenatal multivitamin yeah B12
is a really important one for
plant-based pregnancies something to
consider for people to realize too is
that the people who are not eating
plant-based they're eating a lot of
animal Foods they're also getting
supplemented through B12 because a lot
of these you know cattle Farms are
injecting B12 into the cows as a form of
supplementation for them too because
they're not getting it from the place
that they're supposed to be getting it
anymore so they're supplementing through
the animal yes essentially well it's
kind of like DHA you know you're
consuming the fish but the fish consume
the micro algae yeah except the cutting
out the middleman yeah yeah except for
this is like they're
yeah and that again goes back to the
Natural argument about where if you need
supplements it's not natural but our
food system is supplemented in so many
ways the main source of vitamin D for
most people is dairy and it's or it's
specifically cow's milk but it's added
to cow's milk it's not naturally in
cow's milk
um iodine is found in Dairy because it's
used in industrial cleaning solutions
for dairy equipment it's also
supplemented to cattle
um so whether or not to even know that
you're being supplemented you're being
supplemented yeah exactly and and there
are benefits to this I mean going back
even it's like the folic acid argument I
mean since the introduction of folic
acid enrichment in grains and cereals I
mean there's been a 70 reduction in
neural tube defects uh in the United
States I mean those these These are big
Public Health wins iodized salt you know
Dairy contain iodine has also been
really helpful for overall cognition
especially in children I mean again sort
of it's like we don't live the
natural quote unquote lives as much
anymore and so some of these public
health programs have really had huge
wins and so to say things like
supplements are bad or you know you
don't need them it's just sort of a a
really naive look and not a critical
look of the history of the benefit of
these programs
or the mass majority of the population
yes and are there some good ways to
increase your minerals and nutrients
through pregnancy specifically like what
advice do you have for people through
Whole Foods yeah we we make every bite
count oh yeah and you can share the joke
I was gonna say I feel like my my uh I
don't know what the right word is but I
I kind of think of pregnant women the
same way I think of picky eaters you
know it's sort of like trying to get as
creative as possible and really
maximizing nutrition in every bite I
love that especially especially with
women who you know may have
she's a weird funky time you know like
you might have morning sickness you
might not feel great you might feel
amazing certain times I mean it's you
know really sort of this
um it can be a different state for a lot
of people and so I think you know trying
to to maximize nutrition
um we love smoothies uh one it's a great
way to use things like a fortified milk
which will help with calcium and vitamin
D
you can add in lots of beautiful fruits
and vegetables you can add in nut
Butters to help get in some fat to help
getting adequate calories and protein
this is where a great thing seeds come
in I mean I feel like I drink a smoothie
often uh during pregnancy just because
it was such an easy way to get a
concentrated source of calories in leafy
greens you know it could be a lot
sometimes to eat a big salad which is a
great sort of technique for overall
satiety and weight management but when
it comes to pregnancy and we're really
trying to sort of maximize intake uh
cooking them can be a great way you know
if anyone's ever cooked spinach or kale
you know you take this to nothing you
know when all the the water takes out
and that can be again a really nice way
to get a dense source of vegetables in
do a lot of energy balls with nuts and
seeds and chickpeas we have our Bean
based PBJ balls on our website that were
originally created for kids but that we
loved like both for postpartum and
during pregnancy it's really about yeah
trying to maximize nutrition with every
bite yeah we make a yogurt with like
fruit and cashews and yogurt I mean and
I'm tofu putting nuts and vegetables
into sauces you know a lot of the
plant-based cheese sauces are a great
way to get in like some cashews or
pestos where you can get in different
nuts and seeds and then the leafy greens
which may not be as appealing when
you're not feeling well yeah I have like
white beans and cashews to like even
like a jar of tomato sauce and puree
that up for a nice like hearty protein
Rich yummy fatty sauce yeah I think that
creativity is the key like when you're
pregnant and things can taste different
you always want to just be creative and
nourish yourself in the way that you
best know how see what's available to
you what sounds good in the moment look
up a new recipe with that ingredient
that you know that sounds good how can I
increase the protein how can I increase
the healthy fats in there and getting
sufficient calories can mean less about
eating like three big meals a day like
you did when you weren't pregnant and
more about eating smaller meals more
often that can be really helpful for
women a lot of times like okay I'm only
I only ate maybe half the amount that I
would when I'm not pregnant for this
breakfast that means I need second
breakfast as well and that's a good tip
for morning sickness too is that eating
small frequent meals works a lot better
for people who are nauseous because
being too hungry or too full can both
contribute to nausea and when that baby
gets bigger I mean I feel like towards
the end too it was like
rooms
I can't eat a big meal but I was hungry
and you know sort of that grazing
constant throughout the day is also a
good way to yeah and this is really
about abundance too much I feel like so
often it can be about what don't I eat
what do I have to restrict but really
that's what's so beautiful about this
way including the vibrant whole plant
foods and eating until you're totally
satisfied and eating lots of fresh fruit
like there's so much demonization in the
world of in society about like don't eat
fruit because of sugar but fruit is so
so vital for us it gives us energy and
it tastes so delicious it's so natural
for us going back to the nature yeah
it's like obviously a human food
biological preference for sweetness and
that's really probably because of fruits
because fruits were a nutrient dense
source of both energy yeah and vitamins
in the diet and humans seek it out yeah
what about okay this is a good question
a segue about fruit is fruit and
gestational diabetes a lot of times
people are thinking oh I'm you know I
have gestational diabetes I'm told by my
doctor I have to limit fruit and not eat
food at all or whatever what are your
thoughts and how do you go about that so
there's no really solid research showing
that one specific diet is actually
better than another for the treatment of
gestational diabetes carbohydrate
management any consistent amount is
important for both gestational diabetes
and diabetes outside of pregnancy but
you don't need to limit your
carbohydrate intake and some of the
research has actually shown that people
who are consuming a higher carbohydrate
diet compared to a lower carbohydrate
diet women actually have better
management of gestational diabetes
because they have better insulin
management so it's not about cutting out
these high carbohydrate foods high sugar
foods like fruit it's about
choosing the less refined ones that are
going to help you manage your blood
sugar better and in fact a lot of the
nutrients that are found in fruits are
not things that we would want to limit
these are things that promote overall
health and we want more of in our diet
antioxidants exactly exactly these are
things that are um that are seen in
opposition to some of these health
conditions so it's about eating the
fruit versus the fruit juice it's about
making the Smoothie versus the fruit
juice if you have gestational diabetes
if you don't have gestational diabetes
and you can certainly have a fruit juice
in your blood sugar will rise and it
will come back down just like
um it's supposed to just like it's
supposed to and so much demonization
these days of blood sugar and like
people are suggesting that your blood
sugar needs to be like flat lining which
is just not the way the body is designed
to work and shows a complete lack of
understanding about physiology so
focusing on those whole grains the fiber
rich fruits and vegetables these are all
things that are that are great for
gestational diabetes there also isn't a
consensus of sort of you know the best
diet for gestational diabetes the
American Diabetes Association sort of
just says you know again like Whitney
said focusing on all these Foods so even
this concept that women who are
diagnosed with uh diabetes suddenly need
to follow a low carbohydrate diet is not
aligned with research and also that can
be a really stressful thing you can't
talk about this all of a sudden because
you know you're normally diagnosed later
in pregnancy it's usually around 26
weeks
just suddenly have to shift the diet the
stress of that I mean I you know there's
there is the research especially showing
you know about stress and pregnancy and
that the negative effects it can have
and so this this idea that suddenly
women have to you know cut out all
grains or cut out fruit and start you
know ramping up the protein is not only
not aligned with what is is considered
to be the best source of evidence at
this time but also a really stressful
impactful thing and then one sort of
quick thing I'll just sort of say
because you mentioned I know before like
you know your doctor's saying this most
doctors do not
have a lot of nutrition training and you
know that is something that we are
constantly
talking about and trying to educate on
two because I think for a lot of women
we do we turn to Our Midwives during
pregnancy we turn to doctors and and not
everyone is the same you know people can
always go get additional training but
they don't always tend to be the the
most up-to-date source of nutrition
information yeah that's super important
to preface because there's a lot of fear
like oh no my doctor said this
absolutely a lot of times you know if
you question okay well where did you get
that information they won't really have
the answer for that absolutely and we
have a lot of physician friends who will
Who will attest to that that they didn't
receive that kind of training in their
program so it the onus is on them to go
get additional training and not
everybody does yeah they had to go
outside outside of their traditional
medical training yeah actually
um this is why Alex and I partnered with
Dr rashma Shaw she co-authored the book
nourish the difference I've heard of
that about plant-based nutrition yeah
and we're going to be I think in the
next few weeks releasing a course for
health professionals on pediatric
nutrition walking them all the way
through from fertility through teenage
years
um because it's just that information
just isn't out there that's amazing
that's so needed and so helpful yeah
well and and hopefully to empower you
know more Health more Health
practitioners to to feel really
confident about these sort of plant
predominant diets and also to help
people who do choose to be plan
exclusive or vegan in their pregnancies
or fertility to sort of know like oh
yeah there there are so many benefits in
doing this and here are some
considerations because and it's
evidence-based that's right yeah which
is the most important thing yeah because
especially if you don't if you haven't
looked into the research then all you
hear is kind of the noise and the
nutrition space and you may buy into
some of these myths and once you can
actually look at the literature and see
how plant-based diets are supported by
the literature and actually in line with
most health organizations
recommendations for dietary patterns
Physicians can feel a lot more confident
and be prepared how to appropriately
counsel these patients in these topics
this is a really important part to
mention like you said about the noise
because anecdotes are really powerful
but a lot of people like you really have
to think about how anecdotes a lot of
times have you ever had a time in your
life where you thought oh this
particular thing helped this thing and
then later you realized oh wait it
wasn't that it was this thing like some
some other evidence came into play for
your life and you realized oh it
actually wasn't that that helped me in
whatever area of Health it was actually
something else so and then there's also
the placebo effect and how powerful that
is that's why in science they have to
use the placebo effect because the mind
is so powerful so you can't just take an
anecdote here there here there and then
accumulate what you think is evidence it
has to be well mentally there are
seriously limits to research yeah but
there are reasons that we rely on it yes
the best available evidence like you
said the the common
um the common fault with these anecdotes
is that is attributing a treatment
effect to something when it was really
uh confounding variable yeah so people
feel better when they eat pretty much
any type of diet doesn't matter what
kind of diet you go on people initially
do feel better they often lose weight
and that's likely because of all the
things that they're getting rid of all
the poor health habits they may also
partner their new diet with exercise
with better sleep they're on a Whole
Health kick so it's like is it natural
is necessarily the specific new way
you're eating is it the foods you're
restricting or the foods that you've
added in we can't say or this one
leather effect
you can't because you're not measuring
that yeah so back to gestational
diabetes a lot of research on dietary
patterns is specific nutrients so there
was one great study I think it was also
out of Harvard correct me if I'm wrong
it showed that adding just five grams of
fiber to the diet specifically from
whole grains or from fruits demonized
for gestational diabetes actually reduce
the risk of gestational diabetes by 23
and 26 percent
um respectively so these two foods that
people like grains fruit you have to
limit those if you don't want to get
gestational diabetes or if you have it
you should limit them and in fact these
foods are associated with Better Health
outcomes less risk of gestational
diabetes primarily because of the things
that they contained so again while we
can't say the specific diet is
necessarily prevents or treats we can
say that the foods within this diet have
been shown to either prevent uh reduce
the likelihood of or help contribute to
better blood sugar management and the
reminder that only plant foods contain
fiber so we're talking about where do we
consume a high fiber diet it to be a
diet rich in plant food and you probably
cover this extensively with a doctor B
but it's just like
that's where some of these communities
that exclude a lot of things like grains
and and fruits and vegetables it's like
what are you losing here when you cut
that out you're losing a major nutrient
that's associated with good health in in
so many different areas of nutrition and
so many different populations yeah Dr B
had said very clearly on our episodes
how fiber isn't sexy when people hear
five I think you might be making it yeah
I think he is he's done a very good job
at it it definitely has he talks about
how like you know when people hear fiber
they think like fiber supplements or
something yeah like these like
metamucils powder from like a grandma
and they're not realizing like it's
fiber from Whole plant Foods yes and how
that is so great for your digestion and
all different lowering your risk for all
these different things that you're
talking about I mean we won't dive into
dive into it very extensively but uh
we're just on the tip of the iceberg of
exploring how the microbiome can affect
different prenatal and postnatal
outcomes things like postpartum
depression so and we know that fiber is
what fuels the microbiome so there's so
many things that we don't even
completely understand yet about
nutrition but we know
at least we have the space of knowledge
understanding that these foods are
currently associated with with good
health yeah frankly that they also
benefit these other things as well for
anybody interested in listening to those
episodes check out Dr will bolsowitz on
my podcast we did two episodes on gut
health they were so great he's so
awesome yeah shout out to Dr B we love
it okay so we're kind of coming to the
end of like specifics on fertility and
pregnancy I want to talk about and the
beauty of this is all the stuff that's
related to fertility is also with health
like related to healthy pregnancy that's
right that's what's so great they're not
separate they're all it's all like a
holistic approach yeah you don't have to
switch your diet the moment you become
pregnant everything that's going to help
you become pregnant is also going to
help you have the healthiest pregnancy
that's amazing yeah and a lot of these
things also apply to what's healthy for
for children as well in the postpartum
period and going on to Early Childhood
yes amazing okay so I want to talk about
iron deficiency there's you know there's
a lot to talk about there and there's
something I'm seeing come up a lot in
and again the ancestral world because
this is like a really trendy thing right
now and you know someone might say how
could ancestral be trendy but it really
is becoming a trend it's like a very
it's kind of the thing right now yeah
for a while it was paleo then it was
keto and now it's like nourishing
traditions and sexual actually no I
think after after keto then it was
plant-based and now that's not as hot
anymore you know it just Trends just
come and go and right now it's ancestral
stuff I mean I don't want to give it too
much weight but there's a lot of
anecdotes there and so people are really
interested in like what does maybe a
plant-based you know physician or
dietitian have to say so specifically
about iron deficiency there's this talk
that it's not actually something that
you need to increase your iron if you
have iron deficiency it's actually more
about
um about your copper and getting enough
uh retinol which we were talking about
the problems there
um and helping increase your copper
which will help your iron absorption and
not to take iron supplements saying that
that's actually harmful to take iron
supplements and pregnancy what are your
thoughts
I mean well so so first let's just look
at the data
um regardless of dietary patterns so
whether you're vegetarian vegan
omnivorous uh iron deficiency is the
most common deficiency uh that's true
for both adults and children
uh in pregnancy like I said before it
tends to sort of trend uh the the
further you get along uh in your
pregnancy so uh we know from nhanes data
about 30 percent uh of women again
regardless of diet are iron deficient
copper is not a nutrient of concern uh
regardless of diet we don't see uh
widespread deficiencies in Copper
um we we really don't see widespread
efficiencies in in retinol
um and so this this idea that we would
need to increase both of those when we
we know that there is a true deficiency
in iron especially in late pregnancy I
think really ignores sort of where where
current science is yeah iron needs are
extremely high Dream pregnancy they go
up to 27 milligrams for an average diet
and if you're following a plant-based
diet it's recommended to get 1.8 times
the RDA so that's up to 48 milligrams of
iron a day that's a large large amount
the vast majority of people do not get
that the vast majority of women
um which is why iron is a priority
nutrient in multivitamin supplements and
why like Alex said so many women
experience iron deficiency it's not
because they're not absorbing the iron
it's because they're not consuming the
eye iron because it is hard to get that
much iron from Whole Foods the reason
this matters is because especially when
it comes to late pregnancy being anemic
increases your risk of hemorrhaging
during childbirth and also the third
trimester is when the the baby is able
to really ramp up their iron stores
which is supposed to last them for the
next four to six months once they're
born so it's amazing yeah it is amazing
and it's why the body is so sort of
finely tuned to really ensure that we
are trying to maximize iron intake uh
during pregnancy so we're able to
support the infant afterwards and
telling women that they shouldn't be
taking iron supplements when we have
again very strong data that iron
supplementation is extremely helpful
when it comes to raising iron in the
body and that they need to be increasing
copper instead which again is not a
nutrient that we see a deficiency in
it just can lead to adverse health
effects for both mom and for baby
um the other thing I'll say too is that
there are two different types of iron so
there is heme iron which is
predominantly found in animal-based
sources and then non-heme iron which is
found in in plant-based sources and the
body has a really good way of regulating
iron uptake from non-heem sources so
what that means is let's say you're
taking
an abundance of non-heem iron in through
your diet and you don't need it then
your body is able to easily excrete it
it's not quite the same with heme iron
your body uptakes much more heme iron
which is why when we see risk of excess
iron or iron overload it's not from
non-heme sources it's from heme sources
that's interesting that kind of goes
against the opposite of what they're
saying they're basically saying iron
supplementation which is plant-based
iron is going to cause all this overload
but you're actually saying that our body
recycles that well and it's the
animal-based iron that's actually
causing overload if you have too much of
it yeah the only time that we're really
concerned about iron intake from
supplementation is acute toxicity you
know let's say that you suddenly took 15
of your iron pills at once and you're
getting in 400 milligrams of iron that
would be problematic because it's going
to overcrowd your body's ability to sort
of regulate that but if you're taking a
prenatal with 18 milligrams of iron and
you're consuming an iron-rich diet that
is primarily from non-heme sources
you're not going to have a risk of
excess iron well any other thoughts on
that Whitney I think that pretty much
sums it up I just think this is yet
another thing in the so-called ancestral
community that just has no evidence to
back it up where is this it's true I
look it up and where is this like if I
if I Google it I Google this and I
cannot find anything yeah it's on
Instagram yeah on these posts with
pictures and captions but when I Google
it there is nothing like I page after
page I like can't find that information
like where can I look up what they're
saying and it's like nowhere the problem
with this stuff is that the onus of
proof somehow lies on the people who
didn't make the claim to prove that that
claim is untrue when the people making
the claims they don't have to put forth
any evidence they just say the claim and
then they say look at me and I look
healthy and you're so we're over here
being like how can I even just prove
this claim because I don't know where it
came from I don't know what it's based
on well it appeals to Nature again you
know to to tell someone oh supplements
yeah supplements feel like it's it goes
against what I'm supposed to be doing so
it's like it it buys into that fear
emotion when we talk about like
anecdotes like oh that must make sense
because they're they're saying that
supplements are bad and that makes sense
to me because it's an additional thing
to have when it's just again not in line
with I do have something to add that if
um if the problem was with the
absorption due to a lack of retinol or
copper
um then we should see much lower rates
of iron deficiency in omnivorous
populations that are eating a lot of
meat which is a good source of iron
which consequently consequently comes
packaged with retinol so retinol is
found in animal products so is iron
so is copper so if all of these things
were the ideal way to take an iron and
in the most optimal form then why are we
seeing High rates of iron deficiency in
populations that have a high intake of
these Foods that's a really good point
because it's really not like it's not an
absorption issue it's an issue of people
not eating enough iron yeah and and I
don't want to eat enough plant-based
iron or just any iron any iron a lot of
um you know a lot of people are just not
consuming like even omnivores aren't
necessarily always consuming
um tons of iron iron rich foods yeah if
you were eating a diet rich in in
poultry and in eggs and in Dairy
could be really I understand I mean
those aren't those aren't iron-rich
animal Foods I also don't want to discon
Discount the fact that um when you are
eating a diet comprised mainly of
non-heme plant-based iron sources like
we said before the RDA has increased due
to the fact that non-heme iron has a
lower absorption rate and again like
Alex said that is a good thing for us
it's in order to prevent iron overload
it's a highly orchestrated system to
make sure we're getting the right amount
of iron but to especially during this
time of extremely increased iron needs
and really we say for any plant-based
dieters you want to try to enhance your
non-hume iron consumption so to do that
you can consume iron-rich foods with a
source of vitamin C which can increase
the absorption of Iron by four to six
times I think you've heard this on other
podcasts you've talked about on other
podcasts as well but this this can
happen really naturally you know you're
pairing fruits and vegetables with your
iron rich foods like the legumes the
whole grains the nuts and seeds so this
can happen in your smoothies this can
happen in your bean-based tacos where
you've got some bell pepper going it
doesn't have to be a difficult thing it
often happens naturally in the context
of many diets and especially cultural
diets around the world that could be
lemon squeeze on your green salad
totally something super simple like that
totally or even your steamed greens like
you said squeezing lemon on top with
some salt yeah you've got your tofu and
a stir fry and you've got some lime
juice in there yeah and if you're taking
high amounts of iron and your iron
levels are not going up
then you know I wouldn't think oh it's
copper or it's retinol I would probably
think celiac disease or maybe some other
um gut issue where you're not able to
actually uptake the iron yeah and then
looking factors there how to help that
type of area yeah super interesting well
to kind of round it out it can be a
little bit confusing all the all this
like nutrition jargon like the
supplements and the the nutrients and so
it can just be a little confusing I
think when you're like okay I just want
to eat well I just want to feel
abundance and not restrictive one out of
the final takeaways for women who are
looking for optimal pregnancy
achievement and healthy pregnancies
let's just like break it down simply for
that as we end it here yeah my favorite
simple catch phrase for nutrition is
from Michael pollen it's eat Whole Foods
mostly plants it's very simple you want
to add in the plant predominant aspect
and say do whatever works for you within
that context
making sure that your doing that and
meeting essential nutrient needs is all
you really need to make sure you're
eating a healthy diet not just in
pregnancy but in any any course any
part of your life do you have anything
concur I mean I yeah I I think it's sort
of this this common refrain we keep
saying
eat as as many Whole Food plant-based uh
items as you can if your plant exclusive
ensure that you have adequate intake of
vitamin D and b12 and possibly DHA and
from there you know I think that you'll
you'll meet a lot of needs a cover
letter round it back into the abundance
perspective think about what can I add
to my plate today to make it more
nutrient dense versus what do I think I
need to restrict perfect love that this
is so amazing I love you guys I I wish
you guys could stay here for a whole
week
our families do not you know they're
like come back home you're like we're
never coming home we're staying in
Hawaii saying all these photos of us
around like you know rainbows and
everything and everyone's like great
well we're working kids are at school
yeah yeah your husband's like when's my
homework I'm gonna come on the yellow
Adventure podcast
all right well thanks for being here and
thanks everyone for tuning in we'll see
you next time
[Music]